Jimmy of Jackson's 12 teams over 14
seasons in the NBA very illustrious
career I kind of college basketball
player oh that's what their me yeah you
don't look old that fellas you look
clean to me but feel it that's why
what'd you think of my plan in the big
three yeah I mean I loved it how much
fun we have it on the road are we having
people don't have a clue I was thinking
about this the other day we were sitting
outside at the Campbell House yes and I
can Kentucky and I'm watching the
interaction with the guy and I was
forget who I was said it might have been
Jeff I was huge partner a couple of
people I said it's funny how guys fall
right back into their routine meaning
when we play we get to a city will drop
our bags we say okay listen everybody
meet downstairs in 10-15 minutes we will
get something to eat they'll hang out
watching the big three now that's what
the guys are doing they jump in the car
they went to go watch ticket was a fight
yeah Roman Romanenko Machiko everybody
was very but same even though they tell
different teams they fell back in the
there's old routine except um
subconsciously what are you thinking
about now the beauty of it now I get a
chance to interact with them me and you
hang I get a chance to talk to dr. Jay
George Gervin I mean the fans too
unbelievable bro I mean I know but you
talk to an mba play like Rondo was blown
away like shot and was blown away all
peers blown up people that come in don't
know what to expect you up until they
get there and see it no it ain't an
exhibition game
don't jump back to the Globetrotters
everybody loves if it's not funny games
it's it's competition and I mean the
Brooklyn games the Dallas games
everywhere we've gone Charlotte this
week we're in Los Angeles yeah any think
about the teens too because we were
saying this three teams needed to win to
get into the playoff right deal you have
three teams that would power that
neither lock in a spot you know Three's
Company
coming back going a ballers need to win
so coming into LA the last we
can before the playoff yeah it's still
not determined who's in and right cube
couldn't have written a better script in
regards to Brooklyn yep with the NBA
draft young and NBA Awards it was a high
out come on man
and then the 26 we're in Vegas yep four
which is later that night the McGregor
Mayweather fight now let me ask you a
question what me haha me brother
Mayweather McGregor yeah what do you
thinks could be more physical the big
three finals or the Mayweather McGregor
fight because I think the big victory
finals you see did you see did you see
Mayweather's interview with Steven base
of Appeals yeah now he's turning the
tables because he could
there's ticket sales are problematically
and I calling that fight what when Irish
eyes are blackened you know they were
complaint it was the thrill in Manila
when Irish eyes are blackened so you're
saying that Floyd he's a great promoter
great promoter he's saying that he's
older he's saying even in the Berto
fight a few years ago he said that he
lost a step and he's saying that he's
going to attack Conor right now so
you're saying that that is more hype to
get more people in the stands to watch
the fight absolutely more pay-per-view
but no more money but even not even that
it's a ticket sale the tickets any
pay-per-view you can get a bunch of guys
together bunch of people go by the fight
would you know now we're going to be in
Vegas right may or may not be at the
fight but we or we may or me I just want
to say one thing what I said it publicly
I said Gary Payton hall-of-famer
all-star I heard about invitations
possibly going out to watch the fight a
child if I don't get one I'm just
showing up I'm just I'm just gonna be at
your house I'll find out where you live
it because I'm not paying my money for
that fight Jimmy I want a free ticket
bro I'm a sport athlete you know you
feel me right yeah I like free stuff I
like it too you know now now Gary and I
because we hung before we were at in
Vegas for a fight anything about all
year Rapids or something oh no he didn't
say come on he didn't mention you
whatsoever it now
since you my boy I might be able to
slide you in through the gate come on
Gary pay yeah yes I might be to get you
in the gate that's how you go stand out
because II know that's breaking an
enormous slide you through escort you in
okay I'm gonna say he's with me okay I'm
just saying let me tell you something me
and Jimmy Jackson we were leaving
Kentucky from the big three games our
flight was canceled canceled we had to
drive three hours during the darkness of
night to Ohio Columbus that's where
you're from the state of Ohio one thing
you didn't see happen I told the driver
to pull over as soon as we crossed over
into the state of Ohio because I have a
real problem with LeBron and the
Cavaliers I told the driver to pull over
he said you know we can go to a guest
and I said no I'm gonna leave my mark
right on the side of the road like a
film I'd take a leak I'd be right on the
sidewalk
just something to sweep them in my house
now I must have been asleep during that
I'll remember that that's my house I I
did it because I wanted I wanted or
LeBron enormous I'm the king well what's
your problem with LeBron not my problem
with him as a player my problem with him
is when he first went to Miami okay and
and now all these guys some of his beers
some of them grew up in miring as they
should custom my opinion he's top five
greatest player of all time but but all
this offseason I want to be traded big
three this big for this Kevin Durant
none of these people would be thinking
is if LeBron James the face of the NBA
didn't do this when he first left
Cleveland and what do you think about
this the NBA has outlined schedule
changes the skinny jean implication get
these guys right there are eliminating
stretches of four games in five days and
18 games in 30 days and reduction of 5
games in 7/8 whatever it is and then
travel the travel to one more games but
here here when I came in the league
great night when I came in the league
honestly we put commercial so that means
that if I had it back-to-back game the
next day we had to jump on the first
flight out first thing smoking first
thing smoking commercial flight wait for
our bags and either go to shoot around
back to the hotel most of the time you
can shoot around then eventually the you
know the private planes came into effect
now you would think that would private
plane all the a coupon for all of the
physical therapy restraining with the
healthy eating the workout videos get
the Rolly with the bill dental did that
that this wouldn't be an issue but what
happens is entering but no but what
happens is analytics jump into the
equation and say well the body needs X
amount of rest the flights can hurt you
the game's itself hurts you the minute
so now they put this in the equation and
say now we need more rest in between for
our players it prevents injuries so it's
not just like one player saying that we
need to its analytics because that's how
the league is being run now that say you
need more rest I get it
hi I'm thinking about back in the day
when guys are rod Buster I'll tell my II
before me
yes oh I gotta stop you see them saying
you said back in the day I mean we come
from the same era right I I may be a
couple years older although I look 20
years old it's fine it's fine I don't
care
it's back in the days I mean it's not
back in the ad but come up but stop it
why trying to be no because I really our
eyes are I'm not hurt I know I heard you
when you said yeah he's got one day
though well dick is back in the day or
the back so we put that up for the poll
up for the poll is back back in the day
no back in a day i twitting ball going
up here i know what it is if I say it
you know what it is I got the Mannix bro
I guess a matter okay but okay girl is
the rest the late great Moses Malone no
one played harder than him right he's
kicking and screaming in his grave
talking about you need rest
you know there's a different era Brooks
if it is air okay yes okay okay are
asking me about this I just saying I
mispronounced seventy-six word just laid
three hours well that's a TD yes I know
but here's it's a bro
always is going to be from your era that
it was better right it's always like the
hip hop back your days yes
five games we're better right you think
about lyrically yeah what guys are
talking about the tracks are different
the mindset is different yes compared to
now yeah cuz we're older yes the same
thing is gonna happen before so I'm not
it's like what a lot of guys that talk
about the NBA about older guys you know
they got a lot of stuff too sensei
listen it's called evolution though
right
when you came in the game it was
different than what then they played
before it's the same thing now right
it's different so I don't have a qualms
with a lot of stuff that's going on the
game is supposed to change it's supposed
to evolve it can't stay the same I agree
with that but but I mean you'll say no I
agree with that because I don't want to
come off like like a player hater and
and all that stuff now you know when you
say that you come all guys I know just
say it I know all I am a player hater
but like I just think that you know I
want the players that get their money
they should have rights and all that
stuff and as a guy should rest that's
not my bike my thinks right the whole
way I got into LeBron and pointing a
finger at it is is a is just the sort of
Gangnam I feel like it's the cool kids
club you know there were cliques when
you played in the hallways although I
feel like if you're if you're part of
the banana boat crew if you're part of
this crew and we were on this AAU team
we're gonna play together I'm like you
know the Eastern Conference the first
the first two three rounds and aside
from the Isiah Thomas drama that was
going on with him personally was a joker
you know and and because and now you got
like Carmelo wants to get out of New
York but he only wants to go to Houston
so he could play on that monster squad
and Kyrie what is your opinion on the
carry thing like he took the big shot in
the finals he controls the target in it
why does he want to lead it it's be nice
and information you know these guys well
think about this now meek now this
decision one wasn't made overnight just
had to be a two to three year process
think about it Kyrie comes in resize
this deal as the franchise play this is
my team right here comes LeBron right
LeBron comes in dominates and controls
everything from when I heard that the
family Kyrie they didn't like that too
much because it took the ball
Kyra's hands here's a young player who
was started to grow into what he thought
would be his franchise now he won the
title got the three Kentucky didn't win
anything on the wind run now here's the
thing the bran has helped elevate him to
the status of where he's at right give
him that love as a young player he's
like listen I'm tired of being treated
like little brother right wrong or
indifferent whether you agree - I agree
with it I believe that's a lot to do
with it in regards to the bronze control
over not only him but other players in
franchise but he it's a catch-22 because
with the older player like the laneway
listen I already proved myself I'm good
right let's keep winning Kyrie is still
- the fact that I'm young I still have a
lot to prove now he didn't come out in
public and say I want to be traded how
did that come he went to Dan Gilbert now
I'm not all right out we've got a white
house right donal thinkers Lakers how
did it get out who you know I don't know
come on Joe
no no I know hello you're missed I'm sad
you know one mystery but you want mr.
basketball in Ohio twice
okay blankness but here's the thing if
Dan Gilbert starts talking to another
team about Kyrie it's a whole bunch of
ways just thinking could be leaked now
guy reach can't Mayer thought that there
was a bronze people it could have been
Dan Gilbert but the problem is this I
read Steve Jobs book right yes people
hated working for Steve Jobs right but
they said as much as I hate it I did my
best work when I was under his tutelage
because he demanded nothing but the best
plan for playing with somebody like a
genius like LeBron is not easy right
because of his demand that sometimes he
can throw his players under the bus
Michael Jordan did it magic did it it's
been great guys have done it but how
thick is your skin and your ego I just
think Kyrie watch what happened in Miami
keep in mind D Wade took less money in
order to open up Calcutta Bron to come
back in not a boys right LeBron left and
didn't really tell D way so Kyrie is
like I'm not gonna get
stuck here because we're not going to be
to get big time free agents once this
thing breaks up we're going to be back
in a lottery so why not go somewhere
that's probably more attractive that I
can win and attract free agents I get
where he's coming from
I get where he's coming from I get where
you're coming from you stick around for
a second I got you right we're going to
be right back Jimmy Jackson big three
all everything to time mr. basketball in
Ohio stay tuned Rich Eisen show guest
host by me Michael Rapaport
[Music]
the tape from the book there we go I'm
the argument q-tip that argue a try
alright we're back Rich Eisen show guest
hosted by me Michael raffle you know
that I'm a senior fantasy football
analyst now I heard that okay I heard
you say you were expert yeah okay I'm
just letting you know that my man Jimmy
Jackson analysts for the big three games
are in Los Angeles this weekend it's
going to be epic to mammoth I think they
should be uh you know what's one of the
things I don't know if they show them on
every broadcast the performances
yeah they don't get a chance to see
theirs who do you think is will perform
this week I have maybe a few people oh
yeah in between the games I think maybe
snoop knew get definitely go I think
maybe who knows this la uh who knows I'm
not making any predictions maybe snoop
maybe cube maybe we really like Westside
connect come on I connect a Kendrick I
don't know what you do I'll kill her
come on can't you gotta cut you got to
come out and do the big homeless yes put
it out there I mean it's LA anybody we
might have who knows I'm so excited for
because the build-up on the backup I
think it's the the respect that a lot of
people have for Q I skew that's it it
ain't because of me moto it well because
of think about ll has been to what three
or four games out on the road
I mean loves it so people coming out not
only one to see good basketball but
understanding Ice Cube put this together
and now they're showing them so much
love so much love yeah I mean it's not
love doing it cuz I'm calling the game
and just to see the excitement from the
players the fans and then the
celebrities when they come think about
we were in Chicago all the people we had
I mean it was this DMX performs at half
times I mean it was it was bananas but
that just goes back to the love they got
for Q alright we got a minute left
Jimmy Jackson analyst you played in the
league you were interviewed by some of
the best I am the sideline reporter now
we haven't even got to interview you but
like you see me doing my thing like how
impressive is it to see they're calling
me the Howard Cosell of the big Street
and we I know we only have 40 seconds
left but can you articulate how
impressive it has been to
me man the sideline honesty honestly
yeah I mean I want to say honesty I
don't want it honest yeah I wanted TV
friendly I mean you know we got 26
seconds man I know it's kind of hard to
wrestle all those whole in only because
you're such a professional and mind
blowing you know you got a face for
radio
so you on there I'm needed TV you just
kill it you know what I'm saying and you
know you were Scalabrine beautiful
beautiful all right Jimmy Jackson big
three words we're done thanks for
joining me come on babe we tried to stay
with us the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what attaches